Speaker 1: Welcome, everybody.
I received an incredible amount of reaction
and feedback to yesterday's segment where
we looked at some of the things that attendees
at a recent Trump rally were saying cultists
and conspiracy theorists visibly disoriented
people, clueless individuals, ignorant folks,
etc.
And a ton of reaction from you about what
is fundamentally, you know, when Hillary Clinton
talked about deplorables, these are deplorables.
There's no question about it.
These are some of the worst of the worst participants
to the extent that they're even really participating
in the American political landscape.
And many of you wrote to me and said, David,
how do we fix this?
How do we fix what?
What possible solution could there be to the
fact that these neo reactionaries, as I call
them, are increasingly prevalent and present
in American politics?
And as bad as things are already and as bad
as things got under Donald Trump, we are.
I think many of you were reacting to the realization
that we're only a few House and Senate votes
away from the absolute worst of the worst.
People like Marjorie Taylor GREENE and Lauren
Boebert and others gaining total power of
the United States political system.
They have some power right now, but fortunately,
because you've got a whole bunch of Democrats
and then also some Republicans with whom I
disagree, but who aren't crazy, like the conspiracy
theorists, they don't have total power.
People like GREENE and Boebert.
But we're close, right?
I mean, if we saw a little bit of a shift,
they would actually have real power in the
United States.
And look at the struggle we're in to defeat
this complete and total irrationality.
It shouldn't be this difficult.
These are folks, you know, in a sane country,
it wouldn't be this difficult to keep people
like Marjorie Taylor GREENE, Madison Cawthorn,
Lauren Boebert, even Trump himself in a sane
country.
Trump coming out and saying People are flushing
toilets ten times and Mexicans are rapists
and criminals.
We would have said, Wow, that's crazy.
But this person never has a chance.
They're not going to win the primary, never
mind become president.
But in this country, because of the electorate,
it is that difficult.
In a normal universe, reality and simple logic
would be the overwhelming favorite to win.
It would be the default and it would be the
norm.
And yet here we are.
We're teetering really on the brink of becoming
a country run by people who believe our major
problems are Satan worshiping politicians
and celebrities having to flush toilets 10
to 15 times, theories that aren't even being
taught to kids at school being public enemy
number one athletes who kneel whether Eminem's
are attractive enough to a Fox News host supposed
socialism and communism.
A couple of Dr. Seuss books that are being
taken out of circulation Bill Gates, Adrina
Chrome.
You know, Mexican refugees and immigrants
and their children.
Climate change mitigation as the enemy, not
as something that we need to do.
But that's the enemy.
Windmills causing cancer, woke math, Jewish
space lasers.
I mean, like, think about that's not a short
list.
I could go on.
There are even more imaginary problems I could
tell you about.
And the dangerous part comes in when we think
about who these folks most remind us of.
And now I'm talking about the cult followers
dealing with cultists.
Doesn't always end well for them or for others.
And, you know, think about Waco, the Waco
siege, also known as the Waco massacre, when
law enforcement went to the compound that
belonged to the religious sect, the Branch
Davidians.
Think about Ruby Ridge.
Ruby Ridge, the 11 day siege in 1992 when
it was another one of these cult elements.
We don't even need to talk about the entire
thing.
Jim Jones and the People's Temple and the
Mass Murder Suicide, Heaven's Gate, the religious
movement again.
And I believe there the term mass suicide
is more appropriate.
Maybe it's murder suicide.
Donald Trump got like 47% of the popular vote
in 2020.
If we imagine that half of those voters are
cultists, you're talking about 35 million
people.
If you say, well, only a quarter of them are
real cultists, it's still 17 and a half million
people.
If only an eighth of them are cultists, it's
still close to 10 million people.
So the main question that many of you are
concerned with and you keep asking me is how
do we defeat the insanity?
We all know that with the Republicans and
these neo reactionaries, it's all ignorant,
unthinking projection and hypocrisy and double
standards.
But we know that just pointing out, hey, that's
a double standard.
Like you say, you're against regulation, but
now you're saying regulate social media and
regulate businesses by telling them you can't
require vaccines.
It's a double standard that doesn't work.
They don't care.
It's a feature, not a bug that they claim.
These are our principles, but they abandon
them as soon as it's inconvenient.
You can't really use their own arguments against
them because they don't care.
So is the solution to instead focus on how
these people bring no solutions ever?
They just attack imaginary problems.
Maybe that should be the focus.
Tell us exactly how you would do X and they
don't.
And they can't.
And they have no ideas.
Maybe that's the approach.
I don't know.
But think about what a country run by these
people would look like.
It would without a doubt be essentially a
white Christian, heterosexual, reactionary,
right wing country, period.
We can't ignore the effect that Barack Obama's
presidency as a half black man had on many
of these.
These folks, as upset as they were that a
liberal black man was in the White House.
We saw that they immediately had to start
manufacturing stories about Obama's character
flaws because fundamentally it was never about
policy.
Oh, he went to a church that we don't like.
Look at the things at people Trump's associated
with.
He wore a tan suit.
He's an elitist who wants Dijon mustard.
He wasn't born here.
Birth certificate, etc..
And what Donald Trump did is he didn't create
these people.
But the Trump White House gave these people
the language to express their reactionary
nature with some plausible deniability that
they had been searching for for decades.
For so long they couldn't say the things they
were really thinking because they were so
vile and disgusting and xenophobic and racist
and whatever.
And Trump provided them a language that includes
America First dealing with immigration.
We're going to fix trade.
All of these different things that gave them
the language to say the things they had been
thinking a long time without being totally
branded as what they actually are.
Just remember, they don't want to talk to
each other and actually have the open dialog
on ideas they claim they want to have.
What they actually want is to impose their
ideas from above and silence everything else
while claiming that they are for free speech.
That's what a lot of the battle on social
media is right now.
Their priority is own.
The libs suffocate the ideas of the Libs.
And that's the ultimate goal.
It's the silence.
And at the end of the day, if they get their
way, where do they imagine everybody who isn't
like them will go?
Well, look, in their vision of America.
Do the people they don't like stay with some
kind of second tier status?
Well, that's horrifying.
Do they imagine everybody else leaves a peaceful
segregation, as some white nationalists talk
about?
I don't know.
You can't possibly come up with an answer
to that type of question when you're not dealing
with rational human thinking individuals to
begin with.
And at the end of the day, politics requires
some compromise and it requires some rationality.
But these neo reactionaries believe that they
are acting.
Some of them believe they're acting literally
in the name of God.
With others.
It's a pseudo deity that's at the head of
their cult.
It could be Trump or it could be Marjorie
Taylor GREENE or whoever.
So they won't compromise.
They can't compromise.
And I'm as scared as you are about the path
forward.
If you have some idea about how to productively
deprogram these people, I still want to put
together what might be some kind of coherent
strategy.
Let me know.